each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
I'm very pleased to announce Marcos dial
from Georgia Tech Marcos dial has many
different relationships with Microsoft
he is the p.i for our robotics effort
and CS curriculum that he does but
Stewart tansley and he's not talking
about that unfortunately today he also
has a great presence with our academic
days Cruz he's at one of the most highly
rated tops and that's what we brought
him back here for he has a really
innovative way to make computer science
attractive not just to us who already at
Microsoft but the folks that have never
even considered computer science and if
he's successful then our industry to get
a whole lot more diverse so let's
welcome mark goods dial thank you very
much John thank you so as John said this
is a talk that we I gave on the GDC SC
the game development for computer
science education the games cruise so
here's the story I want to talk about
how important computing is for everyone
and particularly give the context of how
Georgia Tech decided in fall 1999 that
every single student that came onto the
canvas had to take a course in computer
science and why they made that decision
making computing work for everyone is
not something the computer scientists
have been very good at there's a lot of
things that make it very difficult our
models about how we teach computer
science don't extend to everyone very
well so I'm going to talk about media
computation its approach that we
developed in particular for teaching the
liberal arts architecture and management
students on campus about computer
science in a fairly rigorous way one way
of thinking about it and we have this in
both Python and Java for both cs1 and
for a data structures class and by the
way i would be happy not to take all
these books back home with me so please
feel free to grab one this is a both the
cs1 textbooks in both Python and Java
one way of thinking about this that was
quickly relevant for GDC se was that in
some sense in this class we're talking
about how we implement video and audio
effects that are common to gaming echoes
of sounds reversing sounds
background subtraction and chromakey
these are techniques that typically the
game engine might provide for your the
API we're teaching computing and finding
the students are attracted and being
retained in this approach explaining how
those lower level things work and then
this is an approach that connects well
to other approaches I'm going to talk a
little about the Alison media
computation and the work so we'll touch
briefly on genres talking about I'm
involved in the appre effort institute
for personal robotics and education
emerging media computation with some of
that and then I will give you some
assessment results particularly because
Jamie's in the room but I was going to
do it anyway alright so in fall 1999
Georgia Tech decided that all students
at Georgia Tech must take a course in
computer science why most of the reasons
at that time were whether there they
were broader than just computing is good
for you take your medicine it wasn't
that sort of thing first of all Georgia
Tech had just decided as carnegie mellon
university did almost the same time I
mean I think CMU was actually slightly
earlier had decided that computer
science was important enough that it
gets a Dean and it sits at the deans
table so we became the College of
Computing and there was actually
thinking on campus well if it's
important enough that we have a college
it's important enough for everybody to
know something about it there was also
the sense that scientists and engineers
recognized that computational science
and engineering was the future of the
field and that cut we bring computation
into science and engineering to help us
understand things in science and
engineering that that's that the
computing serves as a tool for improving
the understanding of professional
scientists and engineers well if that's
the case if it is a tool to aid in
understanding doesn't it make sense to
provide the same sort of tool to
students in some sense we can tell
stories about telescopes and microscopes
originally developed for the astronomers
and biologists but eventually we say you
know it helps the students too and so
there was some thinking about bringing
the computing to the science and
engineering students surprisingly the
liberal arts college was actually in
favor of making this requirement for
absolutely everyone somewhat surprising
was for me you actually agreed with this
requirement for them it was a way of
differentiating their students from all
other liberal arts students here we have
a liberal arts college at Georgia Tech
well that's something kind of unusual to
have a liberal arts focus an institution
known for science and engineering well
we can really take advantage of that by
urging that place by requiring the
liberal arts students to take to take
computer science as well so in the
nearly ten years we have been trying to
figure out how to make this work and Ken
perlen and his one of the opening
addresses for GDC se made the point that
he's realized that the critical issue of
end user programming is why why would
you want to program and answering that
question is really the critical thing to
answer in order to be able to get
computation computing science for
everyone today though we can actually
come up with even more reasons than the
ones which existed in Fault in 1909 this
is a quote from Richard Dawkins arguably
one of the most famous biologists in the
world and when he was on fresh air with
Terry Gross where Terry Gross asked him
you close your book saying I'm thrilled
to be alive at a time when humanity's
pushing against the limits of
understanding how do you think that's
happening in your field of evolutionary
biology you can read the whole paragraph
but the killer sentence is since watson
and crick in 1953 biology has become a
sort of branch of computer science
here's one of those most world famous
biologist saying we're just computer
science and there's a good argument for
why biologists and everyone who would
study biology should know something
about computer science so I'm going to
occasionally throw up some data up here
don't worry you don't have to know all
of it and there won't be a test later
for the first four years of our
requirement if everyone take computer
science we offered one and only one
course originally was in pseudocode and
then we moved to the teach scheme how
design programs approach this is a time
is actually going so this is zero one
fall up 20 to fall don't you don't have
to look all the numbers the general
thing the pass rate here is fairly low
all right we're looking in the sixty to
seventy percent range of the students
are passing the class and sometimes the
women are failing at almost twice the
rate of the men this wasn't a very good
thing and in general what we're looking
at is that this is Georgia Tech students
Georgia Tech students are really pretty
good and we're flunking them out at
these numbers what's going on here
shouldn't we expect that a smart
students should be able to get through
an intro computing course so what we
came to decide is that what we need is
contextualized computing education
did a problem for this if I walk around
it all for them okay great thank you so
since spring 2003 we now teach three
intro computer science courses our
approach has been informed by the
research that has gone into what's wrong
with computer science education notably
books like Jane Margolis and Allen
Fisher unlocking the clubhouse women in
computing where they point out that we
ought to offer alternative paths to
computer science now that everybody
comes with the same background that
everybody comes with the same interest
we should have multiple paths into
computer science they talked about
explicitly in there that students come
to computer science classes if they come
to computer science classes and as we
know no today that doesn't always happen
because they find that things like
blackberries and tablet PCs the fact
that I can draw on the screen and wheeze
and all of this cool technology our
lives that's why you come into class and
then once you get the cs1 we tell you
how to compute Fibonacci numbers and how
to solve Tower of Hanoi there's a clear
disconnect the end the students say we
don't see why it's relevant that they
seek an intro computer science as
relevant so each of the courses that we
now teach have a particular context all
of the examples the things we do in
lecture the homework assignments are all
connected to a context which is relevant
to those majors so we now teach three CS
ones at Georgia Tech there's one for our
majors or computer science majors and
the majors in the College of Science
this is the one which is now all
robotics that's the one that we're doing
with the astute personal robotics and
education we have one for the engineers
where the programming languages in
MATLAB and all of the problems are drawn
from an engineering context they figure
out how what is the launch velocity to
get a rocket ship outside of Earth into
Earth orbit they they figure out things
like the flow of fluids from one tank
into another tank given a certain
configuration of pumps and pipes these
are real engineering contexts and the
students buy into that and finally
there's the introduction to media
computation the intro to computing for
the liberal arts architecture and
management students I'm only not going
to say too much about the matlab course
it's the latter one which is the one
that I was tasked with them that I've
been trying to develop for the last few
years I will give you a little bit of
the results from the engineers as he
mentioned showed you a moment ago that
in general the cs1 for absolutely
everybody on campus we're looking at 62
seven percent success rates
we did a lot better when we have the
engineers in engineering context so
here's our first piece of data that
maybe this context idea really has
something that the engineers are doing
better now then the whole campus was
thrown into one class so I I was tasked
with teaching the liberal arts
architecture and management students and
if you think about it this belief in
context you realize this is actually a
very challenging problem in general
computing does not pervade the
professions that are engaged they're
engaged in liberal arts architecture and
management not the same way that they do
in science and engineering in particular
we don't know a whole lot of architects
who for example who program it's hard
for me to convince an architect that
it's worthwhile for you to for you to
program so I had to figure out a story
that I could tell in order to make that
make sense and so the story we said is
that for these students computing is
less about calculation and more about
communication that what these students
are going to do with the computer is
communicate things work with digital
media create PowerPoint work with things
like Windows Movie Maker and I movie
that's the context in which we want to
talk about computation so we cover the
same kinds of computer science if you
take an intro computer science class
anywhere you're going to iterate iterate
across all the elements of an array and
compute the average or find the maximum
of things like that how about if we
iterate all over all the pixels of a
picture and compute the grace tale or
compute the negative we always iterate
across a particular range maybe we're
going to change one string and change
all the letters to something else how
about you iterate just over the pixels
around the eyes to remove redeye without
changing the red clothes that somebody's
wearing we talk about algorithms as a
general recipe or process that crosses
different different kinds of data so it
turns out that the algorithm by which
one sound fades out while another one
fades in is exactly the same that used
for blending two pictures and having
some degree of transparency it's the
same algorithm just apply to two
different kinds of media we when the
data structures class we manipulate
linked lists we always manipulate linked
lists in a data structures class one of
the things you commonly do in a linked
list with data structures do you take a
node and you make five or six copies of
it and you take another node and you say
skippa to put one in skip to put one in
take another node skip
one put it in puts when these nodes
contain numbers or strings this is one
of the most boring activities in the
world when the nodes contain MIDI you
are creating western music you specify a
motif you recapitulate the motif you
have a variation on the motif a linked
list ties very well to western music
which is strange thing to think like why
don't we do this earlier it's a lot more
compelling for the students and it
allows us to get into ideas that are
really important really big ideas of our
field that we don't normally get to an
intro course this picture here is the
words this is a test where each pixel
gets mapped each sample of the sound get
mapped to one pixel and then we choose
the color based on the value of the
sample this is a sound visualization now
we have some idea of how winamp does it
then we write another piece of code that
takes this picture and turns it back
into the sound strangely enough you can
hear the words this is a test that comes
through pretty clearly and now you get
this idea of information being separate
from whatever media that it's encoded
within and that's a really powerful idea
you sort of watch the kids explode when
they see that so meaty computation is
showing up in undergraduate classes and
high school classes teacher workshops as
I said we've originally started doing
this for our course at Georgia Tech we
currently have three to four hundred
students a semester now just unusually
it's about 51% female because of the
majors who take this class it's required
in the liberal arts architecture and
management programs one of the cool
things about this this class is that it
has been one of the things which has
enabled us to create a new bachelor of
science in computational media a joint
degree between the College of Computing
particular the school of interactive
computing and the school of literature
culture and communications in our Ivan
Allen College of the liberal arts that
sort of degree program wouldn't have
existed if it wasn't the case that you
could now get liberal arts students to
succeed in an intro computing class that
program in particular is twenty-seven
percent female which is a dramatically
different than most computer science
undergraduate programs around the world
today soon after we did the Python
version Barbara Erickson my co-author
and my wife did the Java version in
order to help high school teachers alert
computing through a media computation
approach and that's what the red book is
here later we've done the data
structures in Java and now there are
schools that are using this approach in
their computer science AP classes their
advanced placement classes and now we're
now integrating media computation with
other approaches like Alice and the
robotics approach so just to give you a
sense of what this kind of this code
looks like we're going to show a couple
examples later on so here's Santa Claus
ok and here's a piece of code for
removing all the red in that in that
example define the function clear red on
a picture for pixel and get pixels of
the picture set the red of the pixel 20
and that gives us the green blue kind of
Santa quite straightforward one of the
things that's nice about Python for
those interested in sort of pedagogical
aspects of programming languages the for
loop in Python is actually a for each
which means that you're saying
explicitly for each pixel in all of the
pixels of the picture we actually know
from a lot of research dating back to
the 70s that without know anything about
programming an eight a natural way in
which people specify loops is not by
looping but by specifying qualifications
you don't say now go through the stack
of files and find all the last names
that start with G you simply say give me
all the last name to the start with G
you don't say check each one and make
sure the first letter is G I mean you
specify as a qualification as a
specification of a set and that looks
more like a set operation so we can
start playing with it eration without
getting through the notion of iterating
through the loop over and over again if
you know something about RGB and it's
very weird to say this with timbaland in
the room you know that that to get a
grayscale you want the red equal to the
green equal to the blue it turns out
that a reasonable way of getting the
right value to set that is to simply
average them it's not great but it works
and so here we're simply getting the
redness green and some blueness
computing an average and setting the
color of that pixel to the where the red
green and blue is all the same luminance
value and we get a reasonable greyscale
Santa how do we negate a picture well
each of these red green and blue values
varies between 0 and 255 turns out that
if you simply subtract 235 from that you
get the reverse of that amount of color
so we're going to create the negative by
making a new color 255 minus the red in
the red slot 205 55 minus the green in
the green slot 255 minus the blow
in the blue slot and we end up with the
goth Santa dark elf look one of the
really neat things about this approach
is that we can give quite open-ended
assignments in the class I want you to
make me a collage and I want you to have
the same picture up here at least four
times the original version and then do
anything you want to the other three but
the same picture scale it crop it make
some other cool to manipulation to it
and then place these all in a canvas and
then mirror them horizontally or
vertically and thus we get these kinds
of images these are not from students
I'm cheating a little bit here these are
actually done by teachers and a teacher
workshop that we ran last summer the
really cool thing is they started first
thing in the morning had never seen
Python and they did this during their
lunch break it was really pretty easy
for them to get started and doing cool
things we do similar things for the
other media that we introduced I would
like to see a movie oops I should move
this into a arrow I want to see a movie
where at least three things are in
motion at once I want to hear a sound
collage where the same sound appears
multiple times we can similarly do
things that are selling about with the
linked list a cannon is a natural kind
of a music structure that our horizons
Oh
oops I don't know why there we go
alright so i'm going to i want to give
some heart some more specific examples
for folks from computer science teachers
who want to see exactly how this works
so we give you some examples from simple
audio effects and some examples from
image manipulations when you're in
physics class and you were told about
how sounds combined you hit all this
stuff about reflections and troughs and
waves it turns out that us that those of
us in computer science have the live
life much easier if we want to combine
two sounds you simply do addition of the
same elements in an array if you're not
familiar with how digital sound works is
that a sound like this oops vector
narrow a sound like this is actually an
array of sample values which is the
amount of pressure hitting the
microphone at any moment and these
values vary between positive and
negative 32,000 roughly 32 k so this
might be 10 11 negative 100 and so on
and the way that you add sounds is to
simply take this plus this goes into
that one and you simply do that across
all the elements and thus you're able to
combine sounds and interesting ways
which here's a very simple piece of code
that simply does that walk through all
the values of the sound grab the two
samples add them together into the
bottom sound once we can combine sounds
we can do blending of sounds we can do
all kinds of things we can do echoes we
can create choruses we can create by
simply adding sine waves together we can
make instruments that don't exist in
natural in the natural world and we buy
doing something called additive
synthesis so there's a lot of really
cool effects one of the really fun
things we do is reversing a sound and I
actually want to show you a piece of
code here okay so this is a sound that I
recorded on the way in oops play sound
welcome to microsoft research that was
Kent normalized a little bit and
actually the code for normalization is
in here we simply walk through get a
maximum find out how to compute the
maximum value multiplied that multiplier
by everything and then we can play the
reverse sound of that
which is we get by running the backwards
code on that now if you look at the
backwards code here all right for all
the computer scientists in the room you
look at this code you say oh well this
is simply reversing an array you have
one pointer that begins if you're at the
end the beginning of the Ray another
point it begins at the end of the Ray
swap values from the source to the
target decrement one increment the other
and keep walking that way this is a
really simple thing that you do in just
about every cs1 but when you reverse an
array-like who cares but when you
reverse a sound and you get to make
sound funny it's a lot more interesting
that's a lot more motivating and that's
the kind of thing that we're after how
do we make this scene turn into a sunset
view we play with things in the class we
try incrementing the red we found that
another way of doing it rather than
incrementing red is to to decrease the
green and blue and so here's a simple
piece of code that does this we tend to
do this live in class try out different
examples reducing the blue and the green
by thirty percent as you see that this
code does I don't have to tell you much
about Python you sort of look at you get
the idea you get a reasonable sunset
view and we can take this into and do
this as a video so here's a piece of
code that's going to grab that that
small beach scene and for 100 frames run
this piece of code which decreases the
blue and green by just one percent and
just one percent means that over 100
steps we eventually remove all of the
blue and green which isn't actually what
you want I mean up to here it's sort of
a cool sunset at this point the Sun has
gone supernova and all life on Earth has
been extinguished but we can still we
can turn this into a movie oops and
about their all life on Earth is
extinguished okay so it's a pretty
simple step then to go from a simple
image manipulation is something you do
over a hundred frames and produce a
little tiny piece of video we play with
a little bit of background subtraction
for those not familiar with background
subtraction you have a picture of a
background without a person I have a
picture with a person which pixels are
the person well if you have the
background and you have the back
with a person all pixels which are the
same in those two pictures must be part
of the background and the rest of it is
part of the person and so we can swap
the background by saying if the pixel is
the same in both pictures go take a
pixel out of someplace else and that's
what we can do is take my daughter
standing against a wall and put my
daughter standing in a jungle or a
forest scene whatever it is now there's
flaws in this there's lots of flaws in
this one of the problems is that my
daughter shirt match the color of the
wall pretty closely and so pieces of the
jungle shine through it's also the case
that I was absolutely awful with the
lighting you can see where the light was
the light was over here and part of her
shadow seems like it's part of what's
going on here now we can tweak that we
can play with threshold values because
what you're doing is saying how close
are these two pixels to one another and
by increasing the threshold that you'll
accept and changing the threshold value
you can make more and more and more of
it match the background color and
actually we can take that and turn that
into a movie alright so we're changing
the threshold value as an input you run
this over the hundred frames and now we
take two people stand against the wall
plus a picture of the wall and slowly
have them fade into the jungle and then
we can turn that into a movie now but
that's using the jungle as the
background what if we simply use the
blank wall as the new background that
we're bringing in then we get sort of a
transporter effect as they slowly
disappear Andy it was when I was doing
this movie you hadn't are you creating
the movies log so they can see as the
pipeline Crothers bermudagrass at the
same time or do they have to run it save
it to a file and then open it up ladder
we're currently what we're doing is we
take some video or in this case these
are just standard standard pictures
we're generating a hundred frames we
then take 100 frames put it into a movie
or we've written little players that
will simply play the JPEGs as if a movie
and we can we can pull in from disk fast
enough that we can get at least 15
frames per second and that's about all
that we really need to do to do these
sorts of effects
now that we know that a much better way
of doing that sort of identification of
where is the person where's the
background is using something like
chroma key chroma key is where the
background is a known color typically
blue and green actually in the class
will take pictures of somebody in front
of a red background and try to wipe out
the red and we find that it doesn't work
you're giggling so you're familiar with
this I mean there's a whole lot of red
in our faces and so just about any time
you try to use red as the as the chroma
key background you end up splashing all
over their face which is where you get
the idea of how they have some really
great monster effects probably got
developed in that way so here's an
example it's really I mean this is not
great chroma key and actually the
algorithm we teach is not the pure
chroma key we don't actually mask and
then apply a mask all we do is look for
where it's blue pull in the pixel from
the from the new background and so here
we go this was actually my son's blue
sheet that I attached to the
entertainment center it took a picture
of myself with this and then I put
myself on the moon all obviously that
I've done this poorly you can see edges
in the moon which didn't show up when
they use the same effect for faking the
Apollo 11 pictures for example yes add
advice yeah I did have a mustache
assault last April yeah the former
students in the back row thing yeah he
used to have a mustache he really did
alright so this example I can show you
in Java we've actually done this all in
Java as well so all we're doing here is
we're walking through for every x value
from 0 to the width for every y value
from 0 to the the height we get the
distance between the current pixels
color and some fixed color if the
distance is less than some threshold
distant get the pixel from the from the
new background and set the color of this
pixel to the color from the new pixel
from the background and thus we can swap
out the moon and then here's this a
piece of code where we're grabbing all
of the frames from a particular
directory this is a directory formed by
my children crawling on the floor in
front of the same blue sheet on the same
entertainment center however this is
actually a negative example which is
actually fun one of the cool things
about this approach is that even the
negative examples are kind of fun to
look at I I was doing this
night and so I had fluorescent light and
so the blue wasn't really blew it was
more black and then when I made it work
well what you see my my son's pants
disappear the hair disappears you can
look right through my daughter's eyebrow
eyeballs and here we're simply taking
each each of the individual pictures and
applying the chroma key effect and then
adding the frame to our frame sequencer
to play out the movies and here's the
resultant movie some see my son's pants
are gone her hair is gone and look right
through her eyeballs into the moon but
it's still kind of a fun effect okay so
as I mentioned now what we're doing is
using media computation with other
approaches as well Alice for as an
example is a environment in which
students learn to program by doing
storytelling in a 3d environment this
was developed by Randy Pausch at
Carnegie Mellon University the it's been
changed into a more of a programming an
introduction to programming approach by
wanda dan and steve cooper we got this
idea this is actually i should i should
point out the original talk GD CSC was
given by myself and my wife barbara
ericsson and this is her part she's the
one working with wanda and steve to
integrate alice with media computation
and she was the one who came up with the
idea of well how do you help students go
from Alice into more traditional textual
programming in something like Java how
do you help students make that
transition well one way that you there
are classes that are doing that and you
take seven weeks of Alice and then close
the Alice we're starting with Java and
you hope that there's transfer between
concepts of variables and iteration and
conditionals and things like that the
approach that Barbara has been has been
developing with Wanda and steve is to
say let's think about java or media
computation more specifically more
generally as the special effects studio
for for Alice you want a particular
sound well we can generate all kinds of
sounds and media computation why don't
you generate the sound there and then
bring it into your Alice world do you
need a particular visual effect you can
develop it out there and bring it in or
maybe what you do is you generate a
annales v and all those lighting
problems with chroma key you can get
perfect lighting in Alice you can set up
the lights any way you want you can have
the background any color you want and
then you can do chroma key with that
here's an example of merging live-action
with an Alice character this is the
Alice character because he hadn't
followed and we simply create a chroma
key background oops and here's my
daughter doing the Funky Chicken with
the jinkin or the reverse of that this
is an alice world where the little
characters are complaining about the
t-rex frightening them and what we're
going to see is that they took a picture
of this one young man lying on his chest
in front of a green screen and he simply
gets chroma keyed into the scene and so
you can see that the idea media
computation here is to enhance what's
going on with the the alice world and
then you it makes for an interesting
moving back and forth using storytelling
continuously as the context but using
the programming with media computation
as being the textual side the technical
side and then bringing the images back
in one of the things that we found i'm
going to show you the results from the
media computation a little bit one of
the things that we found after we
started developing these contextualized
approaches for the engineers and for the
liberal arts majors is that they were
sometimes passing cs1 succeeding at CS
one more than our own computer science
majors were that they were succeeding at
CS one more than our own work so we were
looking for a way of contextualizing CS
one that's when we started getting
involved with the the robotics effort
working with Deepak Kumar and Doug blank
at bryn mawr the idea being if that
robots are a context that computer
scientists the computer science students
recognize as being valid this really is
computer science we know from our
assessments of these students the
students come out saying I am learning
computer science I'm using robots to do
that and that's the kind of thing that
we're after the folks developing this J
summit Deepak Kumar and Doug blank are
developing the curriculum are really
coming up with great things Doug blank
held a piece bot demonstration at the
Franklin Institute in Philadelphia you
know if you can read these signs they
say things like make code not war and
then at Georgia Tech we've been putting
together these complicated plays with
the robots as the characters wearing
various costumes
what Doug in particular has been doing
with my row the language that they're
using is that he has been in creating
media courting the media computation
primitives to their version or robotics
the robot now has a camera on it which
leads for this absolutely fantastic
assignment grab five robots five
students hand their robots you can't get
the robots without the students and put
together a movie where one of the robots
is the camera person how do you zoom you
point and you go forward it's really
great and then afterward they have to do
some media competition it's actually
quite complicated they're really dealing
with with synchrony and concurrency and
how do you make sure everybody's in the
right place at the right time and then
afterwards they do media computation
with what's going on it's very creative
it's very collaborative here's an
example of one of their movies or part
of one
you're traveling to another dimension a
dimension not only of sight and sound
but of mind a journey into a wondrous
land whose boundaries are that of
imagination that's the signpost up ahead
your next stop and twilight zone
so we had this wonderful situation that
we'd never had previously students were
from liberal arts architecture
management we're passing cs1 and saying
could I take some more please and
particularly they told us and this is
something i'll get back to the when we
get to the assessment data they were
telling us they didn't they were dated
Monica Moore computer science they
wanted more media computation which is
actually kind of a frightening thing
that they really saw these as two
separate things so the next normal
course that one would offer would be a
data structures course so we decided to
offer a media computation data
structures course the driving question
for the course is a little bit down here
how did the wildebeest charge over the
ridge and the lion king if you're
familiar with Disney Animation you know
the answer to that question is that this
was the first time that Disney did not
draw their own characters those
wildebeests were all simulated Annika
we're all modeled on a computer and then
simulated in a herd situation that's
what we teach because it takes linked
lists and networks and graphs and trees
to be able to model a scene it takes
stacks and queues in order to be able to
do the simulation we spend 15 weeks
constructing the wildebeest charging
over the ridge or sometimes we'll do
things like in this example this is
actually example taken from the
hunchback of notre dam which was also
done with a similar technique or perhaps
the bad guy walks into the room and the
villagers just step out of the way and
that we're doing this probabilistically
the agents are just milling about and
when they see the bad guy come into the
room they leave the area well not all of
them the Knights are programmed to go
attack the bad guy
so these are screen caps from the the
making of and what you can see is that
to model this model the wildebeest we
need networks and trees to model the
scene and then we create heard
simulations and actually on the on the
making of DVD they actually show you
that the way they work out the
algorithms is with what they call bugs
which are very similar to the turtles
that we use and so in the class we do
disease propagation simulation
predator-prey simulations even political
influence simulation who wins the red
states or the blue states in the next
election we do a lot of the same kind of
open-ended assignments but now we're
requiring students to use objects and
agents this is a class that we've been
teaching in Java so here are similar
collages what we saw previously when you
saw the previous ones you may have been
thinking to yourself I could do that in
Photoshop these are a little bit more
cool more sophisticated so these for
example are not flowers rather it's this
baby picture spun on its axis and
dropped regularly in this one the
student took a picture of the Eiffel
Tower and then negated it and then did
want to think this one's edge detection
in the negation of that and then she
took Turtles and walked across the
surface and drop little tiny copies of
the Eiffel Tower now yes you could do
this in Photoshop if you really want to
sit there and carefully scale and drop
you know 100 images this is really
algorithmic art this is images that one
can only create using a procedure which
is a really compelling way of doing it I
think of motivating procedures okay so
let me talk a little bit about some of
the data in general media computation
students are more motivated and engaged
based on retention data and interviews
and find the course social creative and
relevant I'm putting that in quotes
because we're going to come back to that
this has been a result that is that is
thankfully been replicated at several
different institutions now in fact
people at the University of the
University of Illinois at Chicago just
presented a paper on this at 60 last
Friday that in their own class they're
using a media computation approach and
that one's particularly exciting because
those students it's a majority-minority
classroom its majority african-american
Hispanic students this is me and they're
finding similar success that moving to a
media computation approach has improved
the retention has made the students more
successful and more interested in
computer science we also know that
students in
both of these kinds of contextualized
courses program outside of class
surprisingly perhaps perhaps not for
some of you think about it the engineers
jump from start programming with what we
give them in class immediately they do
it the same semester the programming
outside of their CS 1 which is actually
quite striking till you realize they're
taking calculus often multivariate
calculus and they've never been able to
see what they've been doing before but
matlab has wonderful visualization
capabilities and so they start graphing
and doing 3d images right away with the
media computation approach we did a
follow on a year later after we started
with the course and found that students
told us that yes they were about twenty
percent of the respondents were
programming afterward without having any
other CS classes which is a really cool
result students in the media computation
classes they spend extra time on the
homework they tell us quote because it's
cool because they get interested in the
assignment I taught this class one
summer on a study abroad at Oxford I had
a small number of students and had lots
of office hours and the students would
just take in their laptop and sit down
next to me at office hours and I said
you have a question they said no but I
thought I'd start the assignment and
then you'd be here if I had any and it
was great and so I get to watch how the
students develop things and they'd show
me so what do you think of this that's
great you're done no it's not what I
want yet and so the students would spend
enormous amounts of time on their
collages on their music and their movies
to make it look just the way they wanted
and that's I think one of the real
benefits of this approach that the
students are motivated to get it the way
they want it to get and that's been lead
to more time on task and we hope more
learning hindi cases where like yes
being invited a study where she allows
students to build games right a logo and
I remember one of the Michelle I forget
her lesson did a similar study was to
didn't add on to the study where she
have the students keep journals right
there are expectations for the day and
afterwards what they actually Jean that
day yeah if you could all do something
similar very curse word yeah yeah so do
you find that your students ever have
unrealistic expectations of what they
think what they can do versus what they
think they can do absolutely and so they
end up hurting it in at the last minute
without everything implemented that
want but they've actually had it working
from early on and that's a really
positive thing so typically the way that
I mean I can I can speak to a little bit
about how the students actually program
in this class I could show you an
example of that summer where I asked
them when they made movies to make
something which corresponded to an event
they had while they were in Europe on
the study abroad and the students
scanned in a postcard of Rome and then
took a picture of herself and a beer mug
because she went on a pub crawl in Rome
and so this beer mug chases her all
across the postcard it's really very
cute but in the middle of this a red and
blue rectangle appear on the screen why
did the red and blue rectangle appear on
the screen my students who knew the
media computation in the back of the
room I know exactly what this is first
thing she did is type in the example
program which moves a red and blue
rectangle and then started modifying
that to make her picture and she didn't
dare remove the red and blue rectangle
because who knows what might have
happened had she done that which you
know at lasalle suka gave the the final
keynote at sig see and he mentioned you
know eighty percent of all coding is
modifying somebody else's code it's not
a bad thing for them to learn
programming by typing in existing code
and then modify it to get to what they
want give it a little bit more time she
probably would have gotten rid of the
red and the blue but it wasn't worth it
to make sure she met the deadline so I
think the deadlines force that forced
the issue that make them finish
sometimes it leads them to have to learn
something new the the faculty who are
teaching this class now I haven't taught
this class in a while so when I show you
the numbers these are actually not just
me teaching it so it's not just a gud
Isle of factor you know the developer
teaching the class the teachers teaching
it now Monica sweat and Colin pots
invented a really cool new kind of
collage assignment build me a flag
preferably of a country that you care
about your heritage or where you're from
so like a Mexican flag or Italian flag
but take three images make them sighs
them so that the right size rectangles
and colorize them so that it looks like
the flag it was really very compelling
and we shared this on the media comp
teach Mediacom teachers mailing list and
someone at the University of Northern
Iowa who had a class that was fifty
percent not english-speaking student not
native english-speaking students so from
from somewhere else gave this to them
and said use your own flag
and the students he said they really got
into it they kind of very motivating
except the students from Saudi Arabia
had a very hard time getting the the
Arabic figure in the very middle though
I don't know what it is to show up so
they added to actually go teach
themselves chroma key so that they were
to be able to put the symbol correctly
in the middle of their flag which is not
a bad result to have happen at all so it
gets back to spending extra time I
mentioned here briefly the architecture
of course another course we're exploring
the media cows are e the contextualized
computing education ideas is that we're
now teaching a computer architecture
course for students where the students
program a gameboy in any computer
science course you have some course we
learn how to program at the bare metal
no operating system how does the
processor work how do you load registers
how does memory map typically you do
this on a pretend processor there's a
number of pretend processors out there
and there's simulators for those we
decided to teach this course
particularly for our new computational
media majors programming a gameboy a
game boy has no operating system you
have to program pretty darn low to make
anything work on the Game Boy and the
students go bonkers with it and they
spend a lot of extra time on their
assignments making them look cool which
is a really cool interesting result so
if you remember those earlier numbers
that I showed you we're doing a lot
better than the sixty to seventy percent
that we had previously in overall we're
better than eighty-five percent in terms
of our success rate and you'll notice
that there is virtually no difference
between the men and women in terms of
fail rate in this class anymore now to
compare these to the sixty to seventy
percent that we saw for the original
class so the original was sick and the
60 to 75 percent range is a little bit
of comparing apples and oranges because
that was everybody on campus and this is
just the liberal arts architecture and
management majors so if we look at just
those majors we see a much more dramatic
story so in the original cs1 management
majors were succeeding at a rate of
forty eight and a half percent yes that
means that less than half would get
through each time and that includes two
pits and three Pete's under the media
computation the majority of the students
are succeeding each time a great
majority 87.8 percent
don't be too bad people when they look
at they say what the heck don't history
majors like computing it off this is
very small numbers we don't have a whole
lot of history majors at Georgia Tech
and I should also point out that this is
actually the first this set of numbers
is over a three-year period and this is
over a two-year period so this is not a
single teacher this is a lot of
different teachers using similar
approaches this is from the follow-up
survey a year later where we asked
students did the class change how you
interact with computers and we realized
that the that the definition the problem
was actually a bad question well no I
use a keyboard and a mouse hasn't
changed much how I interact with
computers at all but we did get some
great responses nonetheless that the
majority of the students said yes and
they told us things like this it
definitely makes me think of what's
going on behind the scenes of such
programs like photoshop and illustrator
and that's the sort of result that we
think that you want when you teach a
computing course to non majors you want
them thinking about how the computing is
playing a role in the things they're
doing on a daily basis with the
applications that they use ok some of
the other results we don't know if they
learn the same we really don't know it's
a very difficult thing to measure cs1
learning and the I talked about the lack
of a common reality let me give you an
example in terms of physics so imagine
that we've got three different ways that
we want to teach physics and we split it
up into groups and we say okay what
happened there okay and doesn't matter
what the approach is I might tell you a
story about kinetic energy and potential
energy I'm I tell you a story about
horizontal and vertical velocity
hopefully none of us is going to say
well the air pressure pushes down at the
bottom and that's at the top and that's
why it turns over how do i express to
you computation in a
language-independent way so that no
matter what your approaches you can try
to explain it to me for a CS one major
who only has seen one language it's very
difficult to express computation in a
way that they can talk about what's
going on and try to tell me try to
explain it to me in a way that is that
his language independent I actually have
a PhD student Allison too who's working
on this problem she was trying to come
up with a language-independent way of
measuring cs1 knowledge we're not there
yet it's actually very difficult to come
up with a reliable and valid way of
doing that
at she's trying to use a pseudo code
approached each a very simple pseudo
code on the first page of the test so
they might use the pseudocode for all of
the things that come afterward obviously
you can't go very deep into cs1
knowledge but we're after the surface
level stuff justice so we can get a
baseline comparison between approaches
so we're hoping to get to that while
engaging the majority of students do not
find the media computation courses
relevant to their degrees or professions
so I told you earlier that Margolis and
Fisher found that most people don't find
computer science course a traditional
ones very relevant what does it mean to
be relevant we asked the question we
want to ask people right to do you find
this relevant oh yeah this is relevant
then we started asking people on
following semesters in what way is it
relevant does it help you get your
degree no will it help you with your
profession know any in general I mean
there hadn't done the class but it was
not a clear yes the clear yes was is
this relevant to your life majority
students say yes and we realized that
what we really got to was not that this
impacts your you're going to succeed
better as a liberal arts made you're
going to be a better historian a better
international affairs major rather they
say I live in a digital world I live in
a world with lots of digital media and I
appreciate now understanding what's
going on with that digital media that's
the story that we're getting back which
is really I think it's a reasonable
place to get to but it's a very it's a
much more subtle notion about what does
relevance mean for these students as I
mentioned earlier students do
distinguish between I would like to take
more media computation classes versus I
would like to take more computer science
classes very first very first semester
it was something like sixty to seventy
percent of the students say yes they'd
like to take more of those only eleven
percent said they'd like to take more
computer science to this day it's still
the case we do get students who transfer
into computer science who do take more
computer science it's only about ten
percent but we have much more of them
succeeding and taking their computing
knowledge into the rest of their lives
which is a positive outcome Andy you how
do you measure their communication
skills in some sense like do you think
that they're able to better communicate
to others about the kinds of
computational concepts they're learning
in your class wow that's a really neat
one I don't know I've never tried to
explore that hmm that's interesting so
I'm teaching with this semester a
graduate course on computer science
education research and I actually have
one student who's interviewing intro
computing courses especially students in
the media computation course showing
them to pictures and say tell me in
English what it takes to get from here
to here now he's mostly interested in
replicating like John pains work and
Lance Miller's work to get a sense of
how do people express those processes in
an English language but maybe he'll get
at some of that as well I don't know
that's a great question it's not mean if
you think about it that's not typically
what we go after in cs1 alright if we
ask XS or CS majors how well can you
express computation after your first
course we'd probably be dismal II
depressed because their communication
skills in general are not all that great
after the first semester but I think it
is an interesting comparative question
to ask Congress these are people who may
be CEOs a non computer tech related
companies who hopefully we'll have some
notion of what it means to be to do
computation and a way to spread those
others to indicate that it's important
you're right i think that's that's a
great point now we are getting them in
their first semester so you know the
writing skills might not be a but it's a
great point mean it really is important
and we do get to i mean i'm not going
into much detail on the curriculum but
we do spend time we spent about ten
weeks of the semester on the programming
class and then we spend five weeks on
all the computer science issues that
arise from that so like one of the
questions is why is my movie code slow
slow and it's the case i mean doing
processing over hundreds of images you
know 640 by 480 takes a long time
typically when you're talking about
interative language like python but we
can get into discussions of algorithmic
complexity and i think it's important
that we actually hit on those sorts of
things because for most of these
students this will probably be the only
computing class they ever take okay so
the the bottom line so media computation
is approach to trying to teach computing
piffle mostly for non-majors at georgia
tech but other schools are trying it
with majors as well to teach computing
about through image audio and video
effects and from a gaming perspective
we're teaching the stuff that you're
gaming engine your api might do and it's
clearly something which we're getting
high success rates in terms of retention
students are buying into this it might
be a way of thinking about pregaming or
even as Johnson pointing out to me
film if you want students to play with
film ideas this is a nice way of getting
those ideas about what what kind of
computing is going into film at an early
level refining it ties easily to other
approaches like Alice and robotics and
perhaps gaming as well the assessment
results are promising the retention
result in particular is very strong that
there's about a half dozen schools now
that have replicated some form of the
study Australian National University
University of illinois-chicago South
Carolina State University Gainesville
college and are similarly finding these
increases in motivation and in the
students getting through the cs1 class
which is a big one all by itself here
are URLs I should mention that for CS
faculty we are offering four workshops
paid for by the national science
foundation for free we pay for a big
chunk of travel about two hundred fifty
dollars on all the room and board it
doesn't cost anything and we'll teach
you about how to use these approaches
Barbara teaches these with our Institute
for computing education at Georgia Tech
that's the ice GT the tea party site is
the one for Allison media computation
work it's my group site and where we
have more information on media
computation including media comp teach
is linked to all the various reports
from the other schools on the use of
media computation thank you very much be
glad to take any questions yes sir this
from a obviously computer science point
of view one thing in cs1 obviously you
must provide a lot of libraries to just
load the image opera bisque and all that
other stuff too because one thing to go
through the array and potatoes but
reading the fifth nap header finding out
where the data starts and the files
right and all that other stuff that goes
on has got to be provided by some
problem absolutely we're doing all of
that for the students because no you
wouldn't have you don't have to there
are certainly there are places we're
using a similar approach where for
example if you assume a BMP file the
header is pretty simple reading in all
of the pixels pretty simple there are
places that places that teach that
Jennifer Berg at wake forest university
has actually been teaching classes you
might think about it as media
computation plus plus at the junior
senior year senior year level where they
talk about having students figure out
jpeg encoding and decoding that's
clearly computer science stuff
we want students to be able to make a
picture and start manipulating the
pixels on day one that's right away so
yes we do provide a rich library we can
read JPEGs we can write JPEGs we can
read WAV files we can write WAV files we
can read some other formats we can read
gifts we can read some kinds of mp3s and
the students can manipulate them and
write them back out so yeah we it's a
lot of a lot of scaffolding that we're
providing up front and I think it's a
necessity if we want this to work with
non-majors yes Andy please um have you
ever thought about sending your students
from your media to computation class to
like a lecture or talking computer
science that's given for advanced
computer science students to cysteine
given the concepts early in this class
they think they've even get anything
like what how could they how much did
they get on one of these lectures that
even know what they're talking about it
all it's a great question and we'd have
to we'd have to be a contextualized
lecture but every once in a while we're
forced enough that I Wayne Newton one of
our alums comes back and visits and
talks about whatever the most recent
Pixar movie is and explains what they
did to render man in order to make it
work andy's Wayne is really quite a good
teacher in himself and does a great job
of explaining this in ways that even
those of us who didn't take a whole lot
of computer graphics can understand and
I've had my students to go to attend
that lecture and really come out very
excited about the kinds of things that
he's talking about I actually used some
of his examples myself in my class so we
talked about them blowing up the tera
byte buffer in Linux when they were
doing the incredibles because they were
object modeling all of the things in the
waterfall scene where the monorail goes
in behind the waterfall and that each of
those are the drops is an object with
one e to the negative six transparency
and it's only white when you got about a
million of them and you know you the
students get the sentence of just how
much memory that is and why that blows
things up so yeah I think that if you
stay within the context they're actually
pretty good at handling some more
sophisticated computing ideas John which
of the two languages we should say is a
stronger pedagogical strengths and which
one
which is two languages as the strongest
drinks for manipulating the medium
Python is clearly about a lot easier to
get started with so the very first time
Barbara taught the media computation
Java class this was too high school
teachers who want to become computer
science teachers we got involved in this
because the State Department of
Education and Georgia wanted to have
more computer science teachers computer
science teachers in general are
management or liberal arts majors G does
anybody have a way of teaching them
computer science so they came to us but
they said they wanted to be in Java
because they wanted teachers to work in
the language of the AP so that's why why
why Barbara did this book so the very
first week that she's teaching this I'm
taking the kids off to summer camp ok so
she's teaching it and I'm calling her
each night and it's not going well
they're really startling with public
static void main and declaration of the
type and then on Thursday so I you saw
earlier the computer science teachers
with Python start in the morning and at
lunch they're doing image manipulation
on Thursday I call her up and she says
it happened they finally got it they
were working under collage it takes more
time so it took them four days to get to
being able to do collages but she said
that she showed them horizontal and
vertical mirroring and then some of them
asked how do i do diagonal mirroring
just said go ahead and she says the
whole group of them wouldn't leave at
lunchtime because they were trying to
figure how to do diagonal mirroring it's
like yes you know it's the same effect
that we get with the undergrads we're
seeing it with the high school teachers
as well so Java has a lot higher costs
to being able to do things like this on
the other hand the Java code is faster
one of the things that's really
interesting is when the media
computation intro students take the
media computation data structures class
we asked them at the end which did you
prefer Java or Python and they almost
always say Java and you know my being a
Python fan in my heart of hearts I was
really disappointed by that until we
started doing interviews with them and
realized that's because we didn't get
that far in the Python in the first
semester what they really liked was
calling methods on objects and being
able to say object dot method do this or
object method method cascading that they
really love that and they thought that
was something that Java could do in
Python couldn't because we didn't get
into all of the object and method
manipulation that deeply in Python so
like
oh well but yeah the Python really works
very well for getting people started now
that said my row and there have been
other people the University of Toronto
are porting all of the primitives that
we use in this book to see Python and
that can be really fast depending on the
libraries that they're using underneath
so I don't think it's it's the case that
Java is always faster than Python a lot
has to do with the underlying
implementation of the very libraries
that you're talking about yes sir you
get an eager none CS majors actually
switch the CSS yes I'm where I'm glad
sit because of the blake in the back row
here was an architecture major
originally architecture who took 13 15
perhaps against his will I don't know
it's required of all the architecture
majors fell in love with it became our
TA for many many semesters I can show
you all kinds of movies that have been
generated based on assignments that
Blake created and he graduated last May
right year ago may that's right with his
computer science degree from Georgia
Tech and now he's here so he's doing
pretty darn well so yes it certainly
does happen I don't have exact numbers
because it's actually fairly hard to
track these things for one thing there's
FERPA issues in here the federal privacy
law that if students admit to me that
they transferred that's great I can try
to track them down but depending on what
major they go into and how many years
separated is whether or not I get
permission originally to track them it's
fairly hard to tell I do know that
students do transfer I don't have a
sense of of how many I certainly know
that it's not a lot just from the fact
that only about ten percent of the
students go from the first class into
the second class I can't imagine that
this you know we're certainly less than
ten percent or becoming computer science
or computational media majors Andy ones
who don't succeed at this fast like why
are they not succeeding that's a great
question so last semester we had the
worst fail rate we ever had in the intro
media computation class and I sat down
with the teacher to go through all of
the data to try to understand why we had
a large number of students last semester
who after homework too
doing anything and didn't drop the class
they didn't come to any more exams and
they didn't take any more homework I
don't they just gave up yes there's a
I'll admit this even though it's
anecdotal and not particularly happy
thought we designed the computational
media degree we originally designed it
thinking that we'd have people who could
succeed at computer science but really
wanted to have a more expressive kind of
degree they wanted to talk more about
creativity and expression what we're
finding that we're getting instead is a
some extent we can't really tell we ever
really measured this is liberal arts
majors who think that they can get
through a computer science class decide
the computational media is a better
degree to come out with then literature
culture and communications or literature
one some other major and so what we find
is that these are students who really
don't like program and really are
griping about having to take any program
which seems strange you took a degree in
computational media so there is some the
teachers are telling me that I'm getting
a that a lot of it is whining from these
these majors who find themselves perhaps
in the wrong degree I don't really know
at this time but in general it's fairly
small percentage I mean certainly less
than a typical cs1 syrup slightly to
back those tantalizing world for any
which may relate to their game creates
context get that one down dog gaming
following your attendance at a gaming
prunes what was your current thinking
about how buying computer gaming as a
context for the loan consumer science
which there's a lot of work going on how
does that compare and contrast at work
with me accommodation well I don't know
enough about the the the data on gaming
as a context for CS 1 and cheney knows
this a lot better than i do what i was
actually thinking about and john
certainly what actually meant by the
dot-dot-dot is thinking about media
computation plus gaming or media
computation as a lead into gaming i
think meeting computation is a class
that works pretty well as a context and
we find that integrates well into other
contexts I was actually contacted folks
at the University of Illinois
urbana-champaign we're teaching a media
comput
asian class this last semester and they
said you know if you simply made them
window where the picture is if you could
let me have access to mouse clicks I
could make a game and I think that's a
viable thing and we're going to explore
making those sorts of changes to the
underlying API so that your think about
some sort of a polling mechanism where
you can get the mouse status and that
would be enough to do that if you wanted
but since this does lead into the kinds
of things you do in gaming or in film
context it seems as if it could work as
a pre gaming kind of activity so while I
don't know much about gaming as a CS one
though Diana jus Ephraim Ben Margot had
a really nice talk at GDC se where she
talked about they explore storytelling
with Alice gaming I think they use game
maker the robotics and there was one
other context or the media computation
and she talked about the differences
between them it was a very nice talk to
the proceedings 80 that's between media
computation and like playwriting or
medium computation and would be making
well it's in some sense it's exactly
what the allison media computation is
getting too because it's really about
storytelling with Alice and then
bringing the media computation in order
to be able to get the special effects
that you can't get from just plain Alice
steve cooper taught a version of the
class last year barbers at a little bit
of a disadvantage so Barbara is our
director of cs outreach so she mostly
works k through 12 with other teachers
she's not in a position to try it out
herself in a classroom and now as you
know Steve's now at NSF Wanda is now at
CMU leading up the Alice project so
we're kind of looking for classes to try
it so that we can try this approach from
out from the class that Steve tried last
year it was pretty successful he said he
had the one of the highest success rates
he ever had from his CS 1 and the most
students who went on to the second class
which actually i should mention
anecdotally one of the things that were
finding and we're only getting this
resultant now and we would never see
this at Georgia Tech because we mostly
teach media cavitation and non-majors
the places that are using these
contextualise approaches with cs1 are
seeing a huge uptick in the students
going into their CS to bryn Mauer has
been using the robotics for last two
semesters lat the this semester and
they're coming up semester they have the
highest cs2 enrollments
they've ever had like like by a factor
they showed the Doug showed the the
graphs and it's like double then the
highest I've ever had before it's just
absolutely amazing gainesville college
which is the very first school outside
of georgia tech to a dot media
computation the small two-year school
they almost never offer acs to because
they might only have two three he had
twelve students last semester who wanted
to go on to the second class so it's
really quite intriguing that there might
be something about an effect of getting
students to want to continue on and
because we're dealing with non majors i
mean if you if you sign up for some
place like Georgia Tech and say I want
to be an architecture major you're
unlikely to say tomorrow I think on to
be a mechanical engineer or a computer
scientist they've made choices already
it so it's harder to get them to change
them if you go to some place where the
students haven't made a declaration of a
major yet we're seeing or have in
computer science I think we're seeing an
effective contextualisation help pulling
them along you had a question Kent
question about this combination of alice
+ me an application how young can you go
this is for the middle school for
example or is the high school so
currently they're doing all the
development with Java because they see
this as a context for advanced placement
classes so but there's no reason why any
of it couldn't be done with Python so in
that case could it be done middle school
I don't see why not I don't know that
anybody has tried I think that it's it I
think that it's viable you'd probably
want to think about a follow on course
to to judicial Alice and it within
undergrads you can do it both of them in
one semester that's what steve cooper
found when he tried it it's ain't chose
with middle school students maybe one
whole semester of alice and then one
semester where you merge it so they know
the alice well i don't know i think that
i think the fascinating question and
well worth exploring we're not currently
there sir doing driving this
computational thinking a gentle just for
the Savior happen right jeans a missing
media computation sounds world like
computational thinking you have being
comments on whether you're a subset of
computational thinking just one way this
is the one true way to do computation
think engine so um I think that
computational thinking
is sort of like what we used to call
algorithmic thinking but I kind of like
the computational word better because
piggley what I find when I work with the
non majors for a lot of the 99 major non
computer science applications the
algorithm itself isn't the big deal
right so like four people manipulating
pictures the notion of breaking a
picture up into pixels with each having
a red green and blue value for their
color that's a big deal for them that
something just blows their mind and
that's about data representation less
than so about algorithmic so i think
that i would say that there's a lot of
computational thinking going on here i
think the results were getting clearly
suggests that that's what we are
imparting to these students they are not
coming away saying I want to be computer
scientists I want to be software
developers they're coming away saying
this helps me leave my life in a
different way and that's what i think is
at the heart of the computational
thinking time USC's films for this would
clearly be confrontational thinking for
those folks as they apply computer
technology communicating from Philly
honey slow in early how old do you think
you know how old could the kids get like
your grandparents or something like I
just met at sig see a guy who knocked
Daniel I'm not remember his last name
and I'm it's college search of the net I
met a lot of people at cigna see but him
in particular he is using this with
adult education classes to try to draw
students back into that getting their
undergraduate so you know this is it's
really think about it makes sense if it
works with high school teachers to draw
them into computer science why wouldn't
it work with adults who are thinking
about possibly going back for computer
science degree so I think that's an
absolutely compelling result meaning one
other quick example from sig see that I
was really struck by one of these it's
nice about cometh approach like this is
that the teachers can be really creative
with it too so I met a graduate student
from I'm sorry somewhere near the
University of British Columbia but not
there a smaller school where she heard
dissertation she's working on a PhD
where she is separating audio streams
and so she's teaching a cs1 using our
media computation stuff where the
context is CSI
and the the problem that she's given
them she said this week they're actually
working on it while she was at sig c or
last week here are five sounds they come
from five microphones at these places
around the bank at what time did the
bank robber arrived and what's really
cool about that is that it's using the
same primitives but it's about analysis
rather than synthesis and you could
imagine going much further than that I'm
sure that some of you may make the same
mistakes I do you go to some place like
a church where you can't use a flash you
take a picture and the picture turns out
just absolutely awful and then I load it
up into picasa I press I feel lucky and
I can suddenly see everything there what
filters just happen there can you
imagine giving your class pictures their
stage you know this is the bank robber
working on the safe right it's a dark
picture find the image find what's going
on here you could really teach this
whole course from an analysis
perspective instead of a synthesis
perspective and it would be really fun
so cool things that I learned at 60 so
yes we believe that it really can be
used with it with adults and the one guy
is really trying it out and it sounds
great questions right thank you all very
much